it is day two of a war that until just
yesterday was for many unimaginable and
the scenes that the hour since the
Russian invasion of Ukraine began have
left us bring to mind times that Europe
hoped to have long left behind Metro
stations turned into bomb shelters
civilians arming themselves to defend
their country in heavy shelling in Kiev
and across Ukraine the facts on the
ground and the measures taken to contain
them are moving fast and tonight we'll
take you through what we know and try to
make sense of a series of events that
has left Europeans stunned and in shock
I'm Nicole furlich in Berlin this is the
day
foreign
[Music]
against for months has come to pulse
and President Putin I call on President
Putin to stop the madness of this war
now
you can stop this Bloodshed you alone
are responsible for stopping this
bloodshed
I'm convinced that democracy and the
independence of Ukraine is going to
Prevail
Russia will have to talk to us sooner or
later
talk about how to end the fighting and
stop this Invasion the world will hold
Russia ambleros accountable for
directions
[Music]
welcome to the program we begin the day
with a conflict long predicted by the
west but which many considered
Unthinkable as Vladimir Putin's war
against Ukraine enters its Third Day
Russian troops Advanced families flee
and civilians begin taking up arms caves
mayor says the city has entered a
defensive phase and Ukrainian military
vehicles or entering the capital to
protect it from Russian troops
Air Raid Sirens have been sounding in
cave and other cities prompting people
to take shelter in Metro stations
Ukraine's government says at least 137
of its soldiers and civilians have been
killed across the country President
Putin of Russia has claimed he's willing
to negotiate after Ukraine's follow
Demir zielinski raised the possibility
of discussing a neutral status for
Ukraine
thousands of civilians have fled Kiev
those who remain are taking up arms and
bracing for a violent confrontation
another terrifying start to the day in
Kiev overnight there was more
destruction bombs rained down forcing
residents to flee to Safety in bunkers
Metro stations and sellers
with residents grappling to come to
terms with their new reality
okay
it's hard but I'm Holding On
a nearby house caught fire and there
were many victims and we were waiting
until seven o'clock in the morning in
our apartment in the corridor in the
bathroom until the end of curfew so that
we could come here I work here
I feel mostly tired and anxious
it's so strange
none of it feels real
yeah I don't even know how to relate to
it
above them soldiers on the streets of
central Kiev and reports of gunfire near
the government District
and on the edge of the capital an enemy
aircraft the Ukrainian Army claims they
shot down
meanwhile Ukraine's president sent a
message to Russia
Russia will have to talk to us sooner or
later talk about how to end the fighting
and stop this Invasion the sooner the
conversation Begins the fewer losses
there will be for Russia itself
but in Moscow repeated unfounded claims
from the Kremlin suggest there's no end
to Russia's invasion in sight the aim of
the operation was openly declared
demilitarization and denassification
we want the Ukrainian people or as
President Putin said all the people
living in modern Ukraine to have the
opportunity to freely determine their
future destiny
but for most ukrainians the only future
they're contemplating now is whether to
remain in their Homeland or to flee
let's take you live now to our
correspondent Nick Connelly he was in
Kiev and like so many others has been
forced to flee Nick good to see you and
good to see that you're safe can you
tell us where you are right now and how
you got there
so I'm in vinitsa which is about 200
kilometers Southwest of Kia but it's
taken me more or less 10 hours to get
here
um pretty chaotic scenes as you saw in
that report in Kiev this morning most
people like us having to spend the night
in a bomb raid shelter for people who
didn't have that that would mean a metro
station and then kind of leaving the
shelter to find the city dessert this
morning basically no pedestrians out on
the streets very few cars there's just
some actual looking kind of police
trying to secure the government quarter
and center of Kiev and even though the
curfew doesn't apply during the day
people mostly trying to stay at home
trying to keep a low profile if they're
not making their way out and then when
we tried to leave just an Endless Sea of
cars heading south and west away from
those main Russian offensives coming
from the North and the Northeast people
either trying to head straight for
Poland towards live Ukraine's big city
in the west issue there is that there
has been fighting within about 10 15
kilometers of that main road it's a
pretty scary expect the people being
stuck in in Endless traffic jams with
serious fighting going on close by or
trying to head Southwest as we did but
roads just hopelessly overfilled huge
queues for fuel people trying to take
cash out from the banks fearful that
yeah the banking system might collapse
and their savings would be either lost
or at least temporarily unaccessible
people trying to stock up on food but
not losing hope and not panicking people
really didn't raise their voices you
didn't see people kind of fighting or
trying to push in the queue I think
there is a sense that even though people
had been hoping that this was just Bluff
on the part of Vladimir Putin this was
this political theater at some level
they were prepared for it and had the
kind of emotional wear with all to deal
with all this
one of these last two days been like for
you and your team
obviously we're in a privileged
positions foreigners we can get out
easily you know if I were Ukrainian
right now no Ukrainian man between the
age of 18 and 60 can leave the country
without a particularly special excuse
they are theoretically all liable to be
mobilized for the Army
um and uh obviously you know if things
go
become dangerous in Ukraine I have a
plan B I have somewhere to go most
ukrainians don't have that and I think
we've
seen how difficult it is to be in a bomb
rate shelter because you just don't know
where those uh bangs those explosions
are coming from at least you know as a
as a novice to this it's scary in terms
of just not really understanding if
you're hearing anti-aircraft guns if
you're hearing explosions if you're
hearing missiles I think that does come
with experience my experience in Don
bass is the locals there who've been
exposed to this kind of stuff year on
year they then are able to distinguish
between bigger threats and smaller
threats and can decide whether or not to
stay in bed or to get out and run for
the seller
um but I think the most kind of enduring
them kind of experience here for me has
been that calm and that
um stoic kind of response and you've
even seen people helping each other
there were people giving other people
lifts I saw a lady with a cat in a kind
of travel box who was just waiting for a
lift on the edge of Kiev uh seeing
someone kind of stop and asking her
where she was going willing to take her
to come along
um I think that's the kind of enduring
memory of kind of cute people
being human being
helpful to other people under huge
external stress yeah a lot of solidarity
in these trying times what about the
people who are staying behind are they
just hoping for the best do they not
have a place to go or the means to leave
or are they just staying there and
preparing to fight
I think there's a very strong motivation
to fight here I mean you know ukrainians
are at home they didn't look for this
conflict it was imposed on them by
Vladimir Putin who had been basically
calling the world and indicating that he
was open to further negotiation he'd
spoken to a man on my call the weekend
before and implied that there was going
to be a big Summit and more meetings
than you know the actual uh crossing of
the Border happened while the U.N
security Council was uh in action was
meeting in New York so there is a kind
of sense of revulsion here at that kind
of deception and that attempt to
basically bamboozle the Ukraine and a
feeling that you know these people are
fighting at home in a territory they
know surrounded by civilian population
that's on their side and so even if
maybe in terms of technology in terms of
equipment they might in some things be a
bit behind what the Russians have they
are in a totally different position to
Russian soldiers who for the most part
don't really seemingly understand why
they're here those arguments we've heard
from the Kremlin about trying to
denoxify Ukraine
um those are arguments that the prime
and has barely tried to explain to a
wider public had learned their own
soldiers seemingly
W's Nick Connelly thank you so much and
please you and your team stay safe
European union leaders have agreed to
impose new sanctions on Russia over its
war on Ukraine but they once again held
back from cutting Russia from the global
Swift payment system after resistance
from some countries including Germany
speaking from Brussels EU foreign policy
Chief Joseph Murray confirmed a Russian
asset freeze that will include Russian
President Vladimir Putin and his foreign
minister Sergey lavrov so President
Putin and foreign minister lavrov are in
the list of sanctioned people
together with the remaining members the
Duma who are supporting this aggression
and also with rival members of the
secret Russian Security Council
for more on this let's bring in our
Brussels correspondent Marina Strauss
Marina what more can you tell us about
these latest EU sanctions
the fact that President Putin and
foreign minister Sergey lavrov are on
this list of new EU sanctions is highly
symbolic because it's the first time
your leaders are targeting a Russian
leader so this is symbolic but some say
it remains symbolic because the idea is
to freeze assets of protein and lavrov
in the EU but it's not clear yet what
kind of assets they have and if it
really will hurt them in any way German
foreign minister analina bear book was
here in Brussels this afternoon at a
foreign Minister's meeting on Ukraine
and Russia and she said that these
sanctions are meant to ruin the Russian
economy and she also said that Germany
did not support cutting off Russia from
the Swift payment system because she
thinks that targeting Russian Banks it
was a much
sharper sword
let's keep talking about Swift because
sanctions wise it is considered the
nuclear option right cutting off Russia
from this Global inner banking system
but uh Germany not the only country
um among the EU members doesn't want to
go there just yet why is that
the thing is when foreign ministers are
in general when EO leaders have to take
a decision on foreign policy it always
has to be unanimous so they they agreed
on this packet of sanctions and some say
it's harsh but well you said it Swift is
not included because France for example
Hungary Germany Italy were still against
it and the Germany's reason is is mainly
economical because Germany is very
dependent on Russian gas and if uh if if
if the money cannot be paid for Russian
gas because Russia is cut off of this
system then maybe Russia will say oh no
there we don't deliver any gas any more
and then Germany clearly has a problem
so this is where we are right now but
also Burrell the Chief Diplomat the es
Chief Diplomat who we just heard talking
said that Swift is not off the table
it's not completely off the table and
that a third package of sanctions might
be discussed in the coming days or weeks
if Russia decides to escalate even
further
DW correspondent Marina Stauss for us
there in Brussels thanks so much
[Music]
when bomb is full on Kiev they fall on
Europe
this is happening in Europe not only
Ukraine when missiles kill our people
it's the death of Europeans I demand
greater security for Europe greater
protection for Ukraine as part of a
democratic world
Ukraine's president they're repeating
please for the world and Europe in
particular to come to Ukraine's aid for
more on this let's bring in redislav
Sikorski he's a former polish foreign
minister and now a member of the
European Parliament for the center
rights Civic platform Mr Sikorski thank
you so much for joining us let's cut
right to the Chase has Europe abandoned
Ukraine
I'll answer your question but let me
first correct the information from your
previous speaker Germany is not more
dependent on Russian gas than other
country quite the country Germany only
Imports about a third of its gas from
Russia Poland 70 percent you get most of
your gas from the North Sea and from
North Africa and your own economy
Minister has said that Germany can
survive without Russian gas this is not
about hitting German homes this is about
profits of a few petrochemical companies
um if we want to stop Putin we have to
do sanctions that work
the sanctions that have been imposed so
far will work in a matter of months or
years
whereas Swift works almost immediately
and it brought the Iranians to the
negotiating table over the nuclear
program so I think this is a sanction
that President Putin would notice and we
would depend 70 percent on Russian gas
are willing to impose the the pain of
that on ourselves so social Germany
everybody will have to make sacrifices
in this the former president of the
European Parliament Donald Tusk the
chairman of your party sent out a
message on Twitter today saying I'm
going to read it to you in this war
everything is real Putin's Madness and
cruelty Ukrainian victims bombs falling
on Kiev only your sanctions are
pretended those EU governments which
blocked tough decisions Germany Hungary
and Italy have disgraced themselves you
retweeted this message Mr Sikorski what
would have been an adequate response by
the West to this aggression in your
opinion
well I'm actually in Washington and I
um I have not recently talked to my
party leader but but I'm glad that we
agree uh namely that the sanctions have
to be proportional to the provocation
you know some countries have sent
Ukraine their arms to defend themselves
the United States Britain Poland the
Baltic states
um Germany only very reluctantly agreed
to suspend Nordstrom too and buying gas
and oil from Russia means financing
Putin's War let's let's be crystal clear
about this do you want to finance
Putin's War
and Putin and those around him are used
to sanctions though and they are said to
even have them factored into the
calculations of this war right do you
believe that tougher States like taking
Russia off Swift would that do any more
than annoy him
well this is the the key distinction
they are used to sanctions on Russia
because they will not pay the price of
those sanctions their fortunes are
hidden away in tax Havens in London and
the Caribbean where a swift would work
immediately and of course the most
urgent thing of all is to send Ukraine
the arms to defend themselves Germany
makes some very good arms why aren't you
doing it
um if you don't help Ukraine now we will
then have to spend much more money for a
general arms race with Russia and you
cannot guarantee anybody that Putin will
stop at Ukraine if you read his
Manifesto of July last year and if you
heard his deranged speech to the Russian
people full of lies this is a man whose
cutlings with reality this is a man on a
megalomanian
megalomanical trip for some kind of
Imperial Glory and yes
excuse me I'm gonna have to
um interrupt you there Ukrainian
president volodimir zielinski in the
face of all this has been very defiant
since this Onslaught began but he's also
been extending his hand to Russia
offering to sit down and talk let's have
a quick listen to what he said today and
then get back to you Mr Sikorsky
I would like to address the Russian
president again
fighting is going on in the whole of
Ukraine let's sit down for talks to put
a stop to people dying
that's a sound bite from earlier today
now Mr Sikorski Russia has signaled a
willingness to talk in Belarus about
what the Kremlin calls the neutral
status of Ukraine what do you make of
that
well Ukraine has a neutral status and
it's just been attacked
um there's not that much to talk about
because the Putin simply has to take his
troops home
how can that be achieved though because
we're in the midst of a war and the west
or parts of the West are not willing to
go where you think it would really hurt
Putin so what can be done they need to
change their
their mind and start helping the victims
of unprovoked aggression this is a war
of Conquest Ukraine has not done nothing
wrong to Russia it just wants to be left
alone and Mr Putin should take his
troops home
what has to happen to change those
countries and those leaders minds and
and
make them act you have to increase the
price of aggression by imposing
sanctions that work namely Swift by
making Europe a less dependent on
Russian energy for example by creating a
gas Union and buying Russian gas
collectively by really going after the
assets of his Club of kleptocrats his
own stolen money the money of his family
there are things that that people like
me have been arguing for years and you
had this dismissing uh worries about
Russia as oversensitiveness now is the
time maybe the last time to get real
member of the European Parliament and
former foreign minister of Poland with a
very clear message thank you for your
time
pleasure
let's now bring in constances she's an
expert on European and transatlantic
foreign and security policy at Brookings
institution and she joins us from
Washington now thank you so much for
your time many analysts thought Russian
President Putin would not invade Ukraine
we're now 36 hours in were you surprised
um I'm afraid I was not
um some friends have been calling me up
or writing to me saying that reminding
me which obviously
with all these events I had completely
forgotten that I had warned about this
uh well before Christmas
um
I have to tell you that I have been
worried about this indeed for a long
time and when I read the kremlins to
quote unquote draft treaties that they
submitted to the US and NATO for
immediate signature without changes a
few days before Christmas I thought this
is it there will be a war and it will
not just be about Ukraine so
I was hoping it could be averted but I I
had no point in the past weeks had the
impression that dialogue was getting
anywhere
do you think the West has grossly
underestimated food
well I think the West
has been in a state of complacency and
denial
I would say for at least a decade and
certainly in the last days and weeks
um I think you know sometimes people
don't believe what they have the
strength to bear
and I think that that that's how denial
works
and so
we are now I think discovering that it
was necessary important to take Putin at
his word I think we still need to do
that and we're still not listening
closely enough
and it's it's a really harsh Awakening
but the people are really suffering
we're not the ones who ought to be
feeling sorry for ourselves we're being
shocked out of this denial
the people we ought to be feeling sorry
for is is the people who are being
killed in Ukraine
I'm sorry I'm angry and I can't hide it
forgive me understand yourself
um talking about listening Putin started
this Invasion saying that his country
felt under threat under threat from the
west and from NATO now more NATO troops
are strengthening the Eastern flank is
this the right approach with him you
think
well
look again my first concern is
preventing
human tragedy in Ukraine
Nothing Else Matters quite as much
and I am not sure that Putin is
desirable we may now feel that we would
like to punish him
and I believe that the sanctions that
are being imposed now will punish him
and his inner circle
uh the risk I think is imposing further
sanctions that will also would also
punish the Russian people
I think that that is a risk with the
debate over on Swift the for I frankly
have very ambivalent feelings about
but I do think that the exclusion of
Russian major Russian Banks from um
International markets will have a
massive impact on the regime
um again we of course we owe it to our
more vulnerable smaller Frontline NATO
member states to support them to send
the reassurance deterrence and defense
but again we have a huge a massive
humanitarian crisis in Ukraine on our
hands on something that will is not been
seen in in Europe at least since the U.S
lab Wars of the 1990s part of which I
covered as a journalist and which may
exceed those just for comparison in
those years Germany took in 400 000
refugees from Yugoslavia
um the projections right now are for
potentially four million refugees
leaving Ukraine overall
I'm really sorry we'll have to leave it
there because we're running out of time
she's an expert on European and
transatlantic foreign and security
policy at Brookings institution thank
you so much for spending some of your
day with DW today
thank you very much for having me on